Gary Vaynerchuk went from being born in
the Soviet Union hustlin as a kid
selling flowers and baseball cards to
growing his family's wine business from
a three to sixty million dollar business
launching vaynermedia and having
aspirations to be one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of his generation in March
2009 he signed a ten-year book deal with
Harper studio reportedly for over
$1,000,000 and released his first book
crushing why now is a time to cash in on
your passion in October 2009 it opened
at number 2 on the New York Times
hardcover advice bestseller list and on
the Wall Street Journal bestseller list
on his 42nd birthday November 14 2017 he
launched his Gary fee 0:01 and oo2 shoes
with k-swiss
making him the first entrepreneur to get
a shoe deal they both immediately sold
out the motivation watch top ten with
leave nation what's that believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend here's my take on
Gary V's top ten rows of success vol 11
also if you want to know if Gary being
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence a link to join is in the
description below the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one love the climb I was at the top of
the wine game and I left because I won I
didn't want to do it anymore
and went into marketing where everyone
liked the first article written about me
was like this guy huh
wine Twitter I think the article in the
big advertising magazine was Twitter boy
is what they call me Twitter boy thinks
he's gonna come and win Madison Avenue
hahahahaha they're not laughing anymore
you know and even this game now I can
already feel it I'm like oh man three
four or five years from now this thing's
a wrap I'm gonna be the guy some would
have to start selling oranges or
something you know I gotta figure you
know benefit figure something out
because I lose like I'm about to climb
back to sports I grew up a die-hard
Yankees Jets Rangers Knicks fan the
Yankees and Rangers won their
championships I literally stopped
watching them Knicks and Jets are gonna
take me a minute you know but like but
like I'm just about the color I just
love to climb like even like back to
sports cuz I think it's great analogy
I'll turn on a random game I need to
know who the underdog is that's my team
I'm just about to climb you know like to
me when I see a kid wearing a Steph
Curry Jersey and that kid lives in New
York I think that kids soft
I'm I'm unit he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own City
rule number two be people centric peope
always like I can't get my cashiers to
like work because they're only 12 bucks
an hour like no it's cuz you've never
said hello to them face right so like
I'm very people centric I think there's
enormous ROI either in the short term or
the long term some of the people that
work for me I risk me go on to win an
Academy Award as a filmmaker right like
I'd much rather have her like me than
not like me
you know everybody's playing short term
I don't live as if it tomorrow I'm gonna
die and I'm stunned by how many people
do it's all short term ROI every
decision is short term ROI and I think
that's a huge decision so internally I
spend a lot of time and money my HR
department to big my time that I spend
with employees too much this is what I
hear from all my business associates who
then spend all their time asking me how
I do it your employees for me it's my
employees first then the customer then I
can even begin to think about what the
Senate for me and I've just watched
ninety-five percent of the business and
I interact with start with them then the
customer then they're in place I think
that most of the people are broken and I
think if you have if you are if you're
honest no bull right if it just went
through your mind like I am me then
customer than my employees you will lose
and I can tell you that's the majority
of businesses rule number three be
consistent I am stunned by how many
people here don't realize that the
quickest path to happiness or more
economics in business given the context
of this talk happens to be in the thing
that they love the most yet they're not
willing to eat for the next three to
five years to get there let me explain
it blows me away
that if you're ridiculously passionate
about the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
now stick with me I know this is going
weird that starting your Instagram
account your podcast and your YouTube
channel about Leonardo and Michelangelo
and putting out that content for a
three-year period in the long tail of
the Internet in the way that niche
marketing works if you focus on that
7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning around
that world that literally within three
to four years the practicality if you're
consistent to making between fifty and a
hundred thousand dollars a year in
affiliate email inks and sponsorship
around being the foremost expert of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is a very
fascinating thing how many people here
and across this country right now rushed
to buy cryptocurrency because that's
where the gold rush was I'm just
fascinated by people's passion for the
quick fix versus the marathon I'm
fascinated by people willing to put in
their body to lose 15 pounds that's some
private-label horse from China versus
eating right and exercising let me
promise you something good
and that's how I want to say it
everything special is hardened rule
number four ignore the noise I think the
biggest vulnerability you've got is you
actually value somebody's opinion more
than you value your own like the reason
I've been able to always do my thing is
when I was 24 and people are like oh you
work at your dad's liquor store like I
heard that it's like a chip on my
shoulder you know I loved it I was like
cool keep sleeping on me you know like
I'm glad you're on Wall Street making a
hundred thousand buying BMWs and dumb
jewelry I'll see you in 30 years you
understand like to me the way you win is
you realize you can't hear nobody not
your parents I mean listen you got to
listen to coach and all that I get it
but at the end of the day my guy
yourself you got to get real real quiet
up here I can't hear anything
you go look at my Instagram right now my
first post I'll post something first
hundred replies in one second you're
Jesus
you walk up water you're the best you're
the old-time can't hear him the next
hundred you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
foolish you're a snake oil salesman
can't hear him I'm in my own mind doing
my own thing and that comes with
self-esteem everybody's trying to keep
up with the Joneses I'm not worried
about you being on the in the Hamptons
on a blow-up Swan
I'm not worried about you renting out
cash from the bank and putting it to
your ear I'm not worrying you jumped a
fence and took a photo in front of a
private plane what do you think these
people are doing they're posing patients
long game you know what's amazing about
being an entrepreneur we get to play
forever I'm gonna be working when I'm 96
trying to find my next hustle rule
number five think differently first
thing that you need to think about is
you need to thinking about yourself as
ESPN and HBO and CNBC and the New York
Times the quicker all of you think of
yourself as that everything changes I
literally think that I garyvee don't
compete with Richard Branson or with you
know Mark Cuban I think that Gary Vee
competes with Business Insider
and Forbes and and you know the Wall
Street Journal and complex magazine like
I I don't think about competing with
humans
I spend zero time even debating that and
so I think of myself Carlos is a media
company and so it's the difference
between you know what I think a lot of
people do in our world they turn into
infomercials versus 20/20 if you make
content on Facebook and LinkedIn and
your email and everything you do if you
think of yourself as ABC News if you
think about yourself as fox or CNN
instead of an infomercial changes
everybody's thinking like an advertiser
not as a media company and I think for a
lot of me it seems like you know I'm
watching your kind of behavior that's
why I feel a little bit different
I'm not putting out content like an
advertiser with a short-term goal I'm
putting out content like a media company
with a long-term goal which creates
short-term opportunity it's a very very
subtle but disproportionate reason and
and the luckier you are if you're this
legendary as people are whispering to me
well then that means you're sitting with
something which means you should be
recording all of it
all of it that's right and the way to
think about it is some of you don't have
the dollars to hire somebody yet and
neither did I for the first eight years
the whole d-roc thing and all this
doesn't you know I love whatever wasn't
easy for you Gary
you have d-roc now in it I'm like pick I
didn't have anybody for eight years and
I built up to it and then I had somebody
so like if you've got to do it in selfie
form good and if like for me I can't
write I have a ghostwriter for my books
I have a ghostwriter for my LinkedIn a
medium right now I can't write it's not
how I communicate but I can do video
some of you are scared of video and get
awkward you're more introverted so then
right use the medium that helps you best
communicate and then build around it
rule number six stop complaining nobody
is gonna cry for you they have their own
tears one thing one thing I'm positive
about is how are Y negative complaining
is and how much I'm trying to suffocate
the practice of it I really have been
fascinated by people that have changed
their mindset into understanding that
everything that is not going well right
now is their fault it has been
remarkably important to me in
understanding that everything that I'm
not happy about has is on me it's it's a
remarkably interesting brain twist the
amount of energy spent on things that
you can't control versus being
accountable to what you can control has
been a huge separator for me in the last
four or five years as I've dug deep no
question the quickest way to happiness
is accountability when people start
looking for somebody else to be at fault
whether it's the government or their
aunt or some or their boss they always
lose rule number seven find your why
everybody's putting out the best photo
from their vacation ever
everybody's putting out the most
exciting night of their lives people are
actually now doing things in real life
just for the photo to put on Instagram
and this is very important to understand
because we as humans are wired often to
envy and be jealous and curious and
dwell on not being on that boat and what
that leads to is short-term behavior
everybody's looking to make a quick
dollar so that they can go on that yacht
or go to Ibiza or buy that car or that
bag or that sneaker and this is 100% the
poison that is in the system and so for
me I want to know why why do you want to
be successful for me I didn't even
really necessarily want to be successful
I just couldn't breathe if I wasn't
selling something or building a business
it's all I knew there was nothing else
it was why it was such a bad student I
couldn't even appease the hour I needed
to be a decent student a day because I
needed every minute selling baseball
cards or wine or whatever I was up to at
that point in my life there was no
choice and so that's what I wish on
everybody else I wish that you wake up
every morning and have no choice that
what you do is how you breathe rule over
eight get attention let's say you opened
a bar a barber shop you want to sell
t-shirts like the one big advantage you
guys have look I have a huge company my
company's gonna do 200 million dollars
in revenue I just flew from Kraft we
have Budweiser eight of the biggest
brands in the world chase they still
don't get it I'm sitting the meetings
every day and they're not pouring enough
money into social media that's your
advantage they're still pouring it into
commercials and print and things of that
nature so you know where the attention
is and so social matters but humans and
relationships are just honestly oh man
I said it like I can't explain to you
enough how much I want you to meet every
person look some of you are introverts
if you're an extrovert and you're social
you need to go all-in on the fact that
you got blessed with that DNA that you
love people and you love saying hello
and you've got the leverage of doing
what you're doing now some of you are
introverts right and that's hard but
like
I'm gonna keep pushing too because the
lever just absurd
rule number nine be self-aware most
people here will be successful if they
could be more patient for longer yet
most people will fail in here if they're
delusional and keep doing the same thing
for a long time waiting for the thing to
happen it's one in the same the most
difficult question for me to answer is
when should you stop doing what you're
doing because I actually have to spend
time with you and really look under the
hood to know are you completely in outer
space and have a terrible idea and you
stink and of course we should change it
or the other thing that so many people
struggle with you're so impatient and
you're so caught up in short-term
metrics like how many followers you have
or how many sales you made or how many
leads did you generate that you quit too
soon because nothing happens overnight
it's one in the same and rule number 10
the last something for a very special
bonus clip is make an impact dudes that
were trying to kill it didn't use words
like empathy and gratitude seven years
ago like seeing like sleeved up like rad
dudes roll up to me like you know
kindness dawg honestly I genuinely
believe my great legacy potentially may
be that I made emotionally intelligent
soft skills alpha you know you'll never
believe this is a super interesting to
me the fact that pink was a boys color
and blue was a girl's color back in the
day is kind of how I think about
gratitude empathy kindness I'm like I'm
gonna trick these young dogs into like
thinking this is cool and then one day
in 50 years people gonna be like the
alpha male traits are like gratitude and
kindness and if I can pull that off then
it's like
I'd die if I didn't work like to me my
game my passion like I love my family
more than life but my wife walked into
my art like bedroom tonight and was like
I need you to stop working and be home
she knows that I'd be like look we need
to figure this out or we're just not
gonna be together I can't like it's not
because I don't love her I'm being
serious I know it sounds weird but I'm
just telling you I would suffocate I
would suffocate and so I'm in it for the
game and honestly I'll be honest with
you I I think the quickest way to get
paper is to love the process because
you're not gonna be able to work 15
hours a day if you're doing it for some
new Supremes it's too hard if you don't
love it raise your standard Apple at the
core it's core value is that that people
need passion and not one drop of myself
work depends on Europe it's supposed to
mean
if you want more garyvee check with the
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy continue to believe and
I'll see you there my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur like I
would never take a note